hi I'm RIA I'm a pasty producer as
always I've been challenged to take a
common food and make it fancy but first
I have news this is by far our most
requested picture I like using alcohol
yes if you wanna check it out go to shop
make it fancy calm let's see what we are
making fancy today
drum roll hot dogs
I had hot dogs before I'm more like a
burger person than hot dog so in my
dictionary hot dogs
eats the sandwich I like relish ketchup
mustard basically everything it's not
only hot dogs but I feel like whenever
you eat outside food it tastes better
without bread without toppings
I think this hotdog smells a little too
strong flavor is also a little bit
off-putting
it's weird smell the same color this
might be a tough day at work but as
always I'm excited to make you fancy all
right here it's what I got rosemary sage
fennel arugula ground pork parsley
endive Dijon mustard dill thyme lemon
and eggs from the pantry I got olive oil
flour salt and ok let's get started make
it fancy first boil some eggs I will
need four drop this egg gentle I want to
make a soft boil so I'm cooking for six
minutes and half I love eggs because you
can use it for savory and desire and it
transforms and it's just much girl
ingredients and I also wish I can lay
egg instead of giving a bath have you
seen Panda giving apart it's just like
pops ah
I'm the baby also creepy though it's
looked like a fingers it's looked like a
hot dog okay so it's been 6 minutes and
a half
it's out put it in ice water because if
you just leave it there room temperature
when you peel egg it's very difficult by
few shock boil the egg like this it's
easy to peel I'm going to leave these
acts
about 10 minutes in ice water and moving
on to next step we have hot dogs here
personally I think this is sausage and a
hot dog it's the one with the buns I'm
putting all hot dogs in the food
processor and pulse that's another
reason I'm not interested going to space
cuz the food associate is very limited
this looks off-putting but looks good
for well I'm going to make what do you
think Amy is gonna eat hot dog
I think they eat something soft cuz they
don't have a strong jaw line based on
those you know typical alien looking
aliens you know and I need 500 ground
pork and 1 tablespoon of Dijon mustard
and I'm gonna just straight it and add
some nice greens and I'm gonna start
with sage and I'm just means sage going
in just say Matt's rosemary rosemary is
a little tough so I want to make sure it
is finely chopped rosemary in do
passerine also hot dogs it's just pink
blob so I want to make it look nicer
I'm sorry cozy so I'm adding about 2
sprigs of thyme mix everything nicely
you can use spatula but I'm using gloves
I'm not adding any seasoning for this
mixture called hot dogs is already
pretty salty the fresh herbs and Dijon
mustard walks well to mask the smell now
I don't smell hot dog anymore right so
mixture is ready and I'm moving on to
next step we have soft boiled egg
you want to peel it and I go little by
little make sure it's smooth and not
breaking eggs appealed flatten this meat
mixture from my hand put the egg and
kind of wrap around it
it's soft-boiled so don't push it too
hard
nice big egg wrapped with me call with
flour shake off excess flour of its egg
and coating with egg and going to panko
so panic oh it's Japanese breadcrumb Tom
means bread call it's flour I like it
because it's a little crunchy there we
go
these are looking good I'm going to
clear this station and moving out the
next set my hot dog XR in refrigerator
meanwhile I call this lemon squeeze side
crack two egg yolk so I'm adding 2 TSP
of lemon juice 1 teaspoon of Dijon
mustard and slowly using imagine blender
adding olive oil you can make this with
whisk but imagine blender makes much
much easier when I was walking at the
restaurant I used to make gallon by
whisk your arm feels like a jello
okay so it looks good transfer this in a
glass bowl and this is a little thick I
want to make it a little bit more saucy
and adding one tablespoon more lemon
juice and a tablespoon of Dijon and
season with salt okay this is looking
good
I have whole fennel some people threw
away this part but is it's edible you
should use it I'm gonna kind of pick it
if you're going on hike on Los Angeles
sometimes you can find on the hike pass
you can also use this tempeh I'm going
to use both today trim it and slice
thing next and cutting endive from here
I'm gonna also use some dill to smelt
very nice and refreshing and we have
leftover lemon juice and olive oil so
just kind of season it's a simple salad
so I'm kind of sprinkling everything
very nice my salad is ready so I got my
hot dog egg from the fridge I'm trying
to at the time because I don't want to
crowd the pan I'm frying at 350 for
young high about six to eight minutes
until golden brown or in Japanese kids
nado which is foxy color have you been
to China Island there are foxes and they
are not afraid of humans so sometimes
they pretend they are injured and try to
get food from people nice golden brown
color take this out sprinkle some salt
while it's hot so come back nice feeling
let's bring everything together
we go simple salad and we got hot dog
Scotch egg and we are going to plate it
nice drop and use back of your spoon
kind of soosh nice mount or salad cop to
see who will mental truth nice now we
are done
[Music]
hog dog Scott check very fancy welcome
back area another make it fancy episode
and you look very nice today look at
this look at the material this is yeah
nice right this is Google running in it
sleep in it you can see I think I look
great too thank you do you know what it
is it's a scotch egg yes which I've
never had before
Oh dig in I'm in England it's so good
delicious
what did you make this out of why do you
think you have to give me some sort of
hint it's very iconic America Oh hot dog
yeah yeah oh my god I was like hi great
Italian sausage process there Sariah
there it's one thing studio to dance yes
make it fancy thank you so much for
watching I hope you guys make a home if
you make it tag me on Instagram if you
like my t-shirt go shop make you fancy
tom don't forget to dance make it fancy
[Music]
you
[Music]